hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to agario now before I get
started on this awesome game I just
wanted to say thank you guys so much for
all the well wishes that came out after
I posted the 8 million subscriber
reaction reaction video there was so
many cool pieces of fan art stories
being told and a lot of love that was
pouring out for the community and it
really does mean a lot to me that that
video resonated with so many people so
immediately after that I'm gonna play
this cool game which I've actually been
playing on my own for hours it's really
simple and apparently I was eating in my
hiding spot but if any of you ever
played this game called little fishy or
something like that way way way back
when it was a flash game that basically
the principle is you couldn't eat
anything that was bigger than you and
you could eat everything that was
smaller than you're playing with other
fish but this one is actually like an
MMO because you're playing with so many
other people these are all other people
that I'm playing with and we're all
competing for the same thing now I found
a server that was relatively even as
compared to the other ones but I am my
own little cell here so I'm in order to
oh god how did he get eaten Wow so I'm a
little organism here that's trying to go
around and I'm on a team I'm playing
teams mode right now which means that
I'm on red team and the leaderboard up
there showing the power distribution
between the average sizes of the
complete other team and the reason that
this game is so cool is just that it's
so competitive fast paced or not fast
paced it's kind of slow but the action
just happens in fits and bursts it's a
lot of fun like you'll see as I'm
playing cuz obviously I can't explain it
as well as I can just show it but
definitely definitely I would give this
one a try it's totally free anyone can
play it just it's browser-based you
don't even need to download anything and
I'm just gonna play for a while and you
guys can see what I'm talking about so
there's a guy a DS being a dick and he's
trying to eat me don't even try hey I'm
gonna eat tumblr I can eat him I can do
this mamie always gonna get food see the
point is that you want to stick around
your teammates Oh Eddie
no no no no no no yeah that's right oooo
it's got me and the Hulk pick on my back
them up rose Oh balls eat me
oh no dojin balls eat me Oh where's my
buddies I'm gonna eat you no I'm not
there's Baek come on
afro bottle for Obama some of the name
who's on this game are pretty silly and
obviously the smaller you are the faster
you are and the bigger you are you start
to go way slow but you can do attacks
I'm not big enough to risk it right now
but you can attack other people by
sending out a piece of you to try to
grab on to other enemies and that's good
and bad at the same time because by
doing that and I'll show you in the next
I'll come back when I actually show you
by doing that you risk something and I'm
oh a bad time to lag come on now you
risk because you send out a small part
of yourself and that means that you
split your size and ass so you would
meet like the Hulk up there he can be
eaten by other people because oh man he
got destroyed get Vaughan get Vaughan
he's right there oh he's dead now what's
it what's this
there we go okay so see how I'm - now I
am in a worse position because my mass
has been split up into two pieces I did
grab someone but I risked it and and
like this why it's not good to hang
around and dance you gotta like Juke
people but you can send out okay I'll
get to it later this is just really
complicated go Hulk go and pedobear and
Jacob ah see I got eaten just like that
I'm dead just like that mmm no please
okay so when you're really small you can
hide in these things and the big guys
they can't push me out of there you
Zakhar
don't be doodle okay no W team you ain't
gonna get nobody you ain't gonna team me
the big guys don't wanna like don't want
to restrict or don't wanna go attack the
little guys no balls deep no no it's
hard to get started because there's
already so many people that are probably
big that it's just intimidating and
you're never gonna be able to match up
to in terms of size so you're just like
no balls don't eat me oh oh oh you help
me before help me now no my phone you
got a hot dog more like bye dog what why
don't I couldn't risk we're back No oh
come on
these Hut's don't get here me don't
don't go on go on
oh god they're so scary I'm just big
enough to start attracting the attention
of the bigger guys crap
Oh Quebec's gonna kill me Oh Kovacs
gonna kill me oh oh oh crap okay
all right we're fine we're fine okay
damn it okay no don't go away no one
likes you no way I don't think another
tactic is to try to dance around the
spiky balls because those can break
apart there
- ah I ate yup I ate your milkshake but
your milkshake with you the whole time
Oh watch this watch this
yes come here you ah damn it I almost
had him he he he he he second thought
just before I got there I'm gonna get
your penis I'm gonna get you penis come
back you can blame it all on me oh crap
crap crap
give me back it's so scary
death killer whoop okay I got death
killer death killer duck man
that's what's fun about this game cuz
you get to this point like in the
beginning you're just scrambling around
with your head cut off but now you're
getting to the point where you start
wanting to eat poop come here poop I
want to put you in my belly
hello mr. bean oh crap well mr. bean Oh
mr. bean wanted to give me okay maybe he
actually thought I was the real Marky
move little did he know I was actually
the real Marky move there's no minimum
pedobear Oh
lend me your strength your poor your
huddled masses this don't kill me career
high dog I want you in me Oh
it's getting bad here oh it's getting
bad here oh oh it's getting so bad oh
god it's so bad oh god this is so scary
okay well I just oh man how did they box
us in like that how did Green get so
strong where did all the red go Oh Chris
how could you
and snap Oh was trying to chase me down
who stuck me please I'll you now Oh
Marky no wants to suck you in give give
blow okay nevermind I didn't know you
had friends that wasn't part of the deal
yo Tanya he's that's a good one man half
the fun is just seeing the clever names
the people why go away I'm not that
important please I'm not important okay
this is this was a bad server to pick Oh
God
bad server Tanya East I'm lagging baby
please don't ya come on come on what you
got what you got what is that a whole
lot of nothing that you got I bet it is
you're never gonna get me Paul
Juke you the hell out of you okay what
you doing now yeah that's what I thought
yeah I'm not running or dying I'm using
smarts gone
try try the Marquis mu bye bye bye I'm
like Backstreet Boys bye bye-bye
you couldn't handle my size I'm too big
oh god you're bigger than I thought
yeah you're bigger than I ever thought
possible all day baby oh baby oh baby
yeah that's what I thought
oh look at me oh crap look at me die I'm
dead I'm so dead
I am very dead I am the epitome of dead
and no come on man we got bigger
problems on a less douchey server oh
crap
no no you don't know not today yeah
please feed you to no one these bigs
were all good these big nuts surprised
me hello tiny how's it going there I'm
just a weirdo beardo marquee move ain't
gonna bother nobody until I'm begging
wrong
hello you've seen big and swung please
don't kill me uh-huh are you gonna do
track come on try it try try it
kamehameha
in Russian oh you may got me but I blew
you up
come here over on us come here on us oh
no please no I don't want yes
surrounded conquer store girl oh yes oh
yes oh
Oh lor thank you right in time for a
blorph to happen greens winning actually
whoa there's my team that's my boy
hey my boy get them team go team go
god damn it DS huge ass nuts you're
always skidding in the wrong space these
huge ass nuts I don't want to see you
anymore I've seen enough of you you're
all over the place
frankly I'd rather have some KFC right
now haha gotcha okay so no weather don't
feed him
thank just meme what is wrong with you
Marky moves back together again you get
F my way right about now
funk soul brother hello GarageBand that
was a big big catch
oh that's scary they're about the same
size
okay good neither blue nor blue knob
blue nor blue knob move I see nobody oh
god oh god scary scary scary moment
scary moment scary moment scary moment
scary moment scary scary scary very
scary I'm very scared I'm scared oh god
where's my team where's my team I would
like my team right now where's my
goddamn team let's go red let's go in my
mouth in my mouth oh crap this was not
preferable blue team fix top team thank
you oh you're stuck her face was
delicious like the gym pyre
Oh God the gym fire scary oh the gym
fire so scary
no the gym parts oh don't don't don't no
no oh it's so scary okay tactics tactics
tactics tactics come on
come on baby ooh Jim pyre wants me I
know he does
there we go whoo oh hello hi Deez Nuts
can you come in through my bill
teamwork is key so work with my team go
ball to go go ball to go go border wall
border wall border wall border wall
border wall border
I'm actually learning Korean right now
it's a lot of fun I want to actually be
able to talk with my family
which would be nice Oh God protect man
would dominate wants a piece of me I'm
lagging so badly come on oh this is such
bull oh it's so much bull thank you
Oh God thank you good Oh suddenly these
huge ass nuts don't seem so huge ass hey
love market wires over there man he's
gonna be happy when he finds out that
makes recording all right green still
doing good we got a big hold on this bad
boy we got them by the big huge Nets I'm
looking at you son to opine still around
this team because markiplier raised on
dream team whoa okay Zakia the second
cousin of Bill bikini and we are almost
pull so much food here oh there's alpha
centauri did you run away from something
is there something bad on the way over
there I'm bigger than you now owes Akeem
come here those only pushed you once Oh
these big nuts please god damn it what
oh hey how's it going okay well thank
you for that you just turned this on its
head I don't know why or how or what you
did to do that but thank you thank you
sir Oh Lone Star you're all gonna get it
when I form back up into one
which is gonna happen but don't don't
know know what a bunch of bow that guy
on my team me over because he
wanted nestled in my bosom I wasn't
ready for that Oh take me to dinner
first
ah hmm okay so that is agario agario is
addictive awesome and when it's not
lagging like this it's unstoppable
amounts of fun there's a link in the
description below you can play this game
for yourself it is awesome also I didn't
mention this but I'm in a comic like I'm
in a legitimate comic now a red giant
entertainment who I've been going with
to comic-con with my brother for the
past four years now they put me in one
of their comics and it's available right
now for only $2 plus there's a coupon
code down there that can take 25% off so
you get like 72 pages worth of comic for
a buck 50 not bad at all but on top of
that 5% of the proceeds are going to go
to charity as well so it's all good news
and I forgot to mention it before it was
actually released like sometime last
week but you can check that out it's in
the description too so play this awesome
game check out the comic if you want and
let me know what you think of it thanks
again everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
golde again yes